Mandy starts this hour in Aiken South
Carolina hi Mandy welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi babe thanks for taking my
call
sure I we were introduced to you
possibly about a year ago my son was
taking a personal finance course with
senior materials at our homeschool co-op
and just last and we've been trying to
implement some of the things that you
have suggested but last week my husband
was involved in a surplus layoffs at
work he is the sole breadwinner and he
will receive a termination pay
settlement and we were just wondering
should we use that to pay down our debt
or since he is getting closer to
retirement age if we should invest it
for retirement so what did he used to
make base salary is 66 but normally with
overtime we were around ninety to a
hundred depending on the end of the year
yeah what did he do for a living
um he was a cable repairmen Melton yeah
so what's he going to now home to the
next thing he was there for a little
over 20 years so it's just kind of you
know we don't know okay
and so his severance package is going to
offer him how much money well it's in
this being debated right now and see
they're going to be 26 weeks or 43 weeks
it has not been determined and that's
you know decided by Geneon contract
something said that - okay all right
so the sooner he gets reemployed the
more this is a sign-on bonus
huh extra money like if he got a job
making the same money tomorrow he just
doubled his income for the year
if he gets 43 right yeah if we can if
things work out like I said he you know
he's older he's you know over 50 years
old now so you know those jobs aren't
you know I'm 58 I'm not feeling like I'm
buying I'm still buying green bananas
well physically he's older than that
he's had some health issues and things
like that said there's you know only
certain jobs that he can physically new
is he done no not at all so what kind of
not use his mind this round well that's
our options that we're going through you
know listen I don't I do not like your
white flag you raised in surrender I'm
going to call you on it he's old he's
not freaking old he's 50 he's
middle-aged he's very smart
and he got kicked in the teeth when he
got laid off I agree
our goal was for him to retire though at
59 and a half just because of his health
issues and so that he could pursue you
know advancing his hobby to you know
additional income what's wrong we raise
Labrador Retrievers for service dogs and
for hunting companions can you not make
a living doing that I didn't ask that I
said can you I'm sure you could
yeah let's do it let's open a business
and let's use my brain and our love of
Labradors and let's become the biggest
provider of labrador service dogs in the
entire freakin state of South Carolina
for that matter in the southeast and
let's get rich no you don't it's a hobby
I said get rich I want you to run a
multi-million dollar operation there's a
lot of expense at that too when you do
it the right way so Wow
just no winning with you is there you're
wrong you're bound to determine the
surrender aren't you no I'm not I just I
mean I'm trying to prepare and look
forward or I am turn I am too but it's a
glass half listen he got laid off from a
job that was physically killing him they
God let's look at it that way
now he gets to live his dream of raising
Labradors and making a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars a year thank God
there's a lot of expense Dave okay so
you need to raise two hundred twenty
thousand dollars a year worth of
Labradors because you got a hundred
thousand dollars in expenses so your net
profit is still more than the old job
that was killing him this is a wonderful
blessing if you look at it that way this
is how you need to be looking at this
kiddo because you've surrendered and
you're like how are we going to curl up
in the corner and suck our thumb and
survive on this forty three weeks of
severance 50 best use of that money
that's our business raising Labradors
that's the best moment yes I am because
I handle the money i I know there's two
ways to fix money you can't cut expenses
enough to have no income that's exactly
right
you have to raise your income too and
I'm excited for you
I think that you're on a new adventure I
know it's scared you and I'm with you on
that I understand but you cannot let
your fear make your decisions fear never
makes good decisions this is a time to
be bold it's time to smile again and
remember what it was like when you were
18 and you thought you could do anything
and now life has taught you you can't do
anything but you can do a lot of things
that you no longer believe you can do
you guys got a lot of stuff in front of
you I really think you're going to be
the best 11 or retriever trainer in the
state I really do I think you're gonna
have so much fun and I think there's
gonna be cute little fuzzy puppies
running around all over your backyard to
the point you have to build a place to
hold them all this is gonna be awesome
it's gonna be fun use this time but
don't sit around and grieve this bad job
that he lost this is God saying I've got
something better for you it was a bad
deal it was killing him he got set free
he was released as if he was held
captive he's a prisoner of war that got
out of jail
it's just I hope be able to look at it
like okay you're gonna you got some work
to do kiddo because if you keep looking
at the way you're looking at it let me
tell you what's gonna happen you're
gonna burn through 43 weeks of severance
and you're gonna be sitting there 51
years old broke and then you're gonna
run up a bunch of credit card debt and
say it's because he got laid off and I'm
gonna challenge and say wasn't cuz he
got laid off it's because you never
looked at the layoffs as a blessing
rather than a curse and that's not some
simple pie in the sky think some of the
best businesses that have ever been
started were started because somebody
was forced out of the nest Mary Kay you
ever heard of her Mary Kay Cosmetics
became a multi gazillionaire because she
got sick of being a secretary and with a
single mom at 52 years old and started
the business at 52 years old same age as
your husband and she has a place that's
the size of the Taj Mahal in Palm Beach
and if you buy place the size of the Taj
Mahal and Palm Beach they charge you for
it a lot this is how this works kiddo
you can do this hold on I'm gonna send
you a copy of the book on tray
leadership for your husband to read let
em read it because I'm not sure you're
going to you can do this don't be so
negative you really can do this I'm not
just blowing hot air here
this is where the best businesses come
from a little ounce of inspiration mixed
with an ounce or two of desperation and
people go crazy and they go do big stuff
go do big stuff this is your time still
didn't answer your financial question
did I yes I did
it's an income part of the equation not
just an out go you can't solve this by
cutting expenses far enough